it's childhood obesity awareness month a
time to take steps to prevent obesity
and reduce the stigma around obesity
Nicole bongham from the Southern Nevada
Health District joins us now to talk
about it and talk about forming healthy
habits so thanks so much for being here
with us today nice display we all need
to think about being healthy now the
American Academy of Pediatrics they
recommend these guidelines
5210 did I say those right okay what do
those mean well um they're really simple
to understand guidelines for just
building healthy habits and Children and
Families okay and so the five stands for
five fruits and vegetables each day five
servings of fruits and vegetables okay
we know unfortunately children in Nevada
and adults are not in Nevada are not
meeting that recommendation really so we
have room for growth here okay
um but you know fresh is great but we're
all trying to stretch our food budgets a
little bit further these days so
remember that canned and Frozen count as
well well just look for low sodium
options and fruit canned in its own
juice so we don't get the extra sodium
and right and sugars that we need two
stands for two hours or less of screen
time a day now that's that's what's so
hard is to get our kids off of the
devices as we switch to this this is a
real challenge isn't it this is a hard
one in my family I suspect it's a hard
one for a lot of people because we are
so reliant on technology but there are
some ways that you can start to set some
limits okay to try to cut down establish
screen free times in your home maybe
that's before school or before bedtime
make sure the TV is turned off during
meal times think twice before putting
the TV in your child's bedroom oh man
and we struggled with that yes and it
took a long time before we gave in I did
I get asked about it every week so I
understand that
one is for one hour of physical activity
every day and this does not have to be
done one can executive 60-minute block
it can be done in 10-minute increments
of time throughout the day so it's it's
easier to accumulate it it's really
important it's probably one of the best
things you can do for your children is
to help them get and stay active right
our parents used to say go outside and
play right go outside come home when the
lights turn off sure the street lights
are off but um yeah it's so good for
their physical and mental health and of
course we hear a lot about that these
days too so help them find something
that they enjoy and make a family time
physical activity time yes so you can
play together play together right
outside together you were just promising
us some good weather in the next few
weeks so it's a great time to be outside
and we'll connect with your family and
be active as well what's the zero zero
is for zero sugary beverages oh wow yeah
that's a tough one it is a hard one too
sugar sweetened beverages sodas sweet
teas sports drinks coffee drinks they're
the number one source of added sugar in
children's diets okay and most of them
provide no nutritional benefits sure and
you've got to explain that to your kids
because childhood obesity I can imagine
can carry on into adulthood and what
kind of diseases illnesses go with it
yeah unfortunately children with obesity
as you know as children about 70 to 80
percent of them are adults with obesity
okay and of course it comes with a
number of serious risks for serious
health conditions like Diabetes Type 2
diabetes asthma bone and joint problems
sleep apnea so high blood pressure high
blood pressure exactly so we're really
trying to focus on like you said
building those healthy habits right that
are just good for everybody for for a
lifetime if families need help maybe
they have an overweight child and they
need some help where can they go to get
more info you can find more information
about this initiative and all the
programs and resources we have available
we're partnering with a number of
community organizations this month to be
out in the community to try and connect
people to resources you can find that on
our website which is get healthy Clark
county.org or Spanish at Viva
saludable.org oh that's great thank you
so much Nicole great to meet you you've
been with the health district for a long
time doing great things
nice to meet you thanks for coming in